let's make a jelly gummy drink using
peach rings and Peach cafeco add some
tea drinks to the glass now we're going
to pour some hot water over it and then
we're going to let it melt and mix it up
now we're going to let this come to room
temperature and then let it set in the
fridge for an hour it's set add some ice
and pour in our cow Pico I got white
peach I'm excited it looks pretty good
this reminds me of having like lychee
jelly and boba
whoa that's pretty good it reminds me of
a chewier version of jello babe do you
want to try
mmm it's really good yeah tastes really
peachy it is Peachy there's peach rings
and then Peach calpico yummy it's like
boba's cousin
thanks babe